[Music]
christina that last caller it goes back
to that article i was reading about how
no one can afford a house anymore no one
can afford college anymore no one can
afford yes they can
yes they can you can afford a car
the difference is is that we have as a
culture me included have become spoiled
freaking rotten
and we think that if we want something
we should just be able to buy it
period i want to go to that school when
i want to live in that house where
i want to drive that car
we
and all of us have got walked around
acting like that somehow we're entitled
to live in these mcmansions when you're
27 freaking years old or you're entitled
to go to this school just because you
breathe air
and it's just asinine it's ridiculous
and it really it goes back to the thing
we taught for 20 years 25 years that
probably the number one
most powerful financial principle is
contentment
yep well i mean i think as a culture
we're starting to build up certain
things to where people assume they have
to have it you know with college
everybody needs to go to a fancy private
school or at least everybody in your
community might be going so you think
you need to go you know everybody for
young adults you may be seeing all your
friends getting three thousand square
foot homes and think you gotta have it
and it's like you don't really need to
start there you can get there eventually
but that's not where you need to start
and it's kind of crazy seeing what's
happening in the world of college a lot
of these colleges now they're set up
like five-star resorts they've got lazy
rivers they've got these beautiful dorms
with all these amenities like you're
basically staying at a beautiful resort
the freaking ritz carlton
for your 19 year old
to play beer pong in
so a lot of people get out of college
and then they think you know if this is
where i lived in college then i need to
upgrade i need to have a beautiful
apartment and a great location by myself
and have all these amenities and that's
just not true and i just i love that
last caller the fact that she was living
with someone in a room for 200
in new york like that's amazing she
figured out a way to work it out it's
not glamorous you know it's not going to
be the most beautiful luxurious setup
but she was willing to make sacrifices
now so that she could graduate debt-free
and have a great future
now i sold them
in 30 years abruptly in the call
but if i get someone that calls in and
it's like well you know you've got these
two 700 car payments
these escalades have got to go i mean
this is ridiculous you all have lost
your minds here and you've got to get
rid of these escalates i can't get rid
of escalate
yeah you you don't really have a choice
no we'll have to have to work on
something else i can't sell the escalade
pop you're gone i'm done dealing with
you i'm not trying i'm not gonna try to
talk you in past that once you're that
obstinate and you're that stuck on
driving an escalade
you're not ready for me to help you
because i can't really help you you're
gonna have to go i'll drive anything
i'll do anything i'll work anywhere that
is legal and moral i will do whatever it
takes i have had it i'm sick and tired
of being sick and tired i'm ready to
change my life and i'm not going you
know five million dollars in debt to get
a degree in left-handed puppetry from
some famous stinking school or the lazy
river this is just ridiculous right it's
ridiculous it's how we got to this epic
student loan crisis and the stupid
government just keeps writing these
checks writing these checks why because
the government is stupid
they're just straight up stupid they
have no off button i had a little pug
dog and that dog we could not put food
out
because whatever food we put out it ate
it it did not have an off button for
food and that's congress it does not
have an off button it will eat it until
it just explodes
the little dog would get so fat that we
had to just quit feeding it it was you
know and congress is the same thing
they're just fat it's ridiculous it's
all off of you people me well i think
that's what's so hard with a student
loan crisis right now and all this talk
about student loan forgiveness and if
it's going to happen if it's not going
to happen i think so many people are
wondering you know if it does happen
then are we changing the way
that college works like are we going to
make college cheaper now like how do we
prevent then the next generation from
falling into the exact same trap
you know like we want student loan
relief we want people to
have freedom from their student loans we
want them to pay off debt but we also
want to prevent the future generation
from walking off the same cliff
no what's the purpose of saving this
bunch or you got to turn and save the
next bunch right you gotta quit making
the stupid loans and it's it's
it's intellectual dishonesty to keep
making loans while you talk about
forgiving them because they're so evil
and it needs to stop and he says stop
but it all comes down to
this sense of entitlement arrogance
versus a sense of of contentment and
that was what was so beautiful about her
that's what brought this up
coming out of that break was uh you know
you said hey let's talk about these
colleges and how they're out of control
because she chose a school she can
afford a living situation she can afford
a work situation that would make it work
she's finding her way
right through it you know absolutely and
i think that's the thing is like we have
to make going to college debt-free cool
like we got to fight this culture that
at whatever expense at whatever cost you
got to go to the big prestigious school
with the you know fancy ranking like if
you can do that and you get scholarships
to do it if you get financial aid to do
it that is awesome but if it costs you
the next 10 years of your life
that's not worth it it's just not worth
it you know and we walk around ramsey
solutions you know we're super
competitive workplace it's hard to get a
job here it's really competitive but
when you walk around you'll see people
who went to community college you'll see
people who maybe didn't get go to
college and they just hustled really
hard and learned a certain skill you
know you'll see people who went to ivy
leagues and we're all working in the
same workplace together and we all have
to get our job done it's just the same
go figure who knew